[Music]
all right so yes I am wearing a neck
brace yes I have a pinched nerve
possibly because I was carrying Isaac or
TIFF during that photo shoot session we
had over the past weekend look at his
back would you just do today I went to
the chiropractor just got back from them
and they diagnosed me Lord please shut
up right sure
yeah well the point is he had cuts you
got cut I looks crazy good do you feel
better right yeah I feel a lot better
you like hmmm abilities earlier this
morning I was in the back end that's
what I was doing I was like yeah hey
it's uh where she anyways besides the
pinched nerves
what do we got I think we got new piano
we got a piano it's pretty cool we're
gonna we're gonna build this baby
yeah just gonna assemble this all by
ourselves watch she's the handyman here
[Music]
Open Sesame
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right so I am in Palm Springs on a
work trip with JK I'm actually in being
out of town away from LA for about a
whole week and spent four days here in
Palm Springs and then I'm gonna spend
three days in New York it's gonna be a
whole week away from TIFF and you know I
pretty much work with TIFF and JK we
work together on this blog channel we're
together we're married we raise Isaac
together so we're pretty much stuck
together all the time and actually this
is the first time we're gonna be
separated as a married couple for a
whole week doesn't sound like a big deal
probably to you guys but it feels like a
big deal to me is for the past five
years we've been like stuck together
like this me and TIFF so I guess we'll
let's see what life is like without each
other for a whole week
[Music]
so it's been officially two days since I
went to go see the chiropractor and I
have to give it to Bart you've
recommended me that power practie and
that man dr. King you are a miracle
worker
because in two days you got me moving my
neck still work in progress but from the
way it felt into the way it feels now it
feels like America it's a neck brace
alright so we're out here in Palm
Springs working on another draft of JK
movie another writer's retreat and this
time I brought Steve with us the three
of us me Bart Joe in the craft of
writing were simply beginners and so for
us to bring in Steve who has multiple
scripts under his belt we really needed
his guidance and experience to push us
through this first movie and Wow it's
just it's like bringing it on the Brawn
James with Kobe on to your team it's
like we got a movie all right so Casey's
been gone for about two days now and
I've just been home alone cuz Isaac's
been at his dad's house too so it just
been so lovely but not today because
today the ladies and the babies are here
yeah we're doing like this little
get-together since all the guys are out
and they're doing their you know writers
retreat in Palm Springs so we're like
you know what all the ladies should get
together and have a little something
some - so get some Thai food yeah put
some babies to sleep yeah
play some murder trivia yeah so I
ordered jack box TV so we're about to
play that right now Nikki oh well the
drinks all gone but Nikki made this
delicious drink what you put in so good
do a whipped cream vodka and pineapple
juice 1 part whipped cream vodka two
parts pineapple juice so good it's like
my go-to drink like with people yeah
Mike you want something simple but
delicious do that yeah it never fails
cuz this thing was amazing I don't even
like the taste of alcohol like hard
liquor
but that drink is really yummy yeah we
got Jeff and Gio and tight this is
bedtime already you know so funny I was
playing with him for the longest time
and I swear Tyco never has like an angry
or mean face he's forever so happy such
a happy baby I love this voice so much
and now he's sleeping I get up cutie pie
goodnight and he was the only boy in a
room full of girls he's so sweet and
then Leia Leia sleeping to look at her
oh your mama's boobies with milk and
today was the first time I saw Leia like
smile she was glowing she's so beautiful
you happy you guys made such a beautiful
baby and her hair is so cute you aliens
I don't think yourself
I did such a bad job I should have been
vlogging earlier when they were all
awake but we're having a good time
yeah I wonder what kids is up to right
now all right it is 3:00 a.m. January
29th 2018
it's late can't think but we finished
our first draft of as of right now in 30
seconds was the name of that working
title of the movie and feeling good
bureau in rock star man can do it that's
right
[Music]
all right what's up y'all I am now in
New York Palm Springs as a blast we
actually finished the script and that
was crazy we purposely tried not to vlog
that specific trip just because with the
vlogging stuff and then you know the
last time we did this you know writers
retreat thing you know we were cooking a
lot too and it just became a distraction
from what we were trying to do in the
first place which was the writing part
this time make no mistake we wanted to
be undistracted and really just get down
to business on the movie project of ours
I'm just so excited that we actually
finished it it's just the first draft so
the writing process is not done but we
are on our way finally we just got back
from Palm Springs last night and I
stopped by the house for just a few
hours because I had to fly out at the
very next morning to New York and the
flight was early so I got had to leave
in the middle of the night basically to
the airport and this is actually my
first time doing that I've never had
back-to-back trips like business trips
where I had to like come home just for a
few hours
repack you know new clothes because Palm
Springs was worn New York is not so
never experienced that before I feel so
much like a grown-up right now I feel
like a businessman like oh cool we
stopped in for the house grab some stuff
and peace out again when I did stop by
in LA me and TIFF we talked a little bit
last night before going to sleep
you know just talked about how you know
Palm Springs went and how the writing
sessions went I was funny because I was
telling TIFF I was like yeah we know we
you know balanced our time from writing
we take breaks and just talked about
life talked about the girls and you know
it's married life
she started laughing I was like why are
you laughing and she said it's funny
that when the girls met up they spoke
nothing of the guy apparently Taiki and
Leia stole the show and it was just more
about just babies and girls stuff the
irony of it all is the fact that we were
talking about the girls we talked about
our relationship yes stereotypically you
know guys aren't the ones to do that
guys are the ones that kind of go into
that guy world and you know do guy stuff
or whatever and the girls are
stereotypically the ones that do get
together and talk about relationships
and feelings and stuff like that so yeah
so I've been invited out by dove to New
York to be a part of a project of theirs
and I don't know too much about it but I
guess I'll find out tonight
they're so nice to have gifted me some
sugar FINA
[Music]
hey guys so today is Tuesday Casey just
left to New York and I'm here in the
Dickey party set here's the set there's
Kane and Kaia
oh it says I left my heart and make it
go actually now my heart is in New York
I don't know what to say to that but
yeah Casey was just texting me he just
landed and I miss him more you know it's
funny when he was in Palm Springs like
the last three days I was like I'm just
go have fun right and like yeah I miss
you but it's like whatever but then now
that I know he's like across the whole
country like and I really miss you so I
was just texting home I got really miss
you he's like I know it's so cold over
here I need a hug from you to warm me up
or something
all right so I'm finally ready got rid
of the head hair and we are going to go
eat dinner with doves it's so cold man
my lips are like freezing shut walking
today was miserable no gloves no scarf
my hands were cold I didn't want to
carry the camera like the actual camera
around so I carried my phone around
became a point where I couldn't swipe up
on the phone and I couldn't tell whether
my hand bruise is too cold and it were
just like - ridge it - for the phone to
read that I was trying to swipe up on
the camera or even press anything on the
on a touchscreen or the phone which is
too cold and it wasn't responding to
what I was trying to do I could I really
couldn't tell my hands were numb I
brought my thickest jacket that I had
but it wasn't New York thick it was like
it's too thick for LA but it's not quite
thick enough for New York standards note
to self
next time you go to New York KC or the
next time you do anything that's in cold
weather where the place is actually cold
and not not just LA cold but I actually
cold bring a scarf bring some gloves
anyways tomorrow I'm heading back to LA
mist if you know you know the whole
thing of you don't realize what you're
missing until it's gone yeah I thought I
would enjoy New York I get to do exactly
what I want because no one else is here
to tell me not to do whatever I'll get
to eat whatever I want to eat I'll get
to see what I want to see and yeah none
of that happened
it's just not fun by yourself I don't
like traveling by myself it's good to
know good to know me and TIFF had this
had this idea for our honeymoon where we
would go to two different countries by
ourselves she would go to one country I
go to another and we would vacation
there and after like a week apart we
would then meet at a different country
in have her honeymoon
eat up you know literally meet up
together for the second week and it
sounded great at the time and I thought
how cool we get to travel by ourselves
I've never done that before and there's
something I've always wanted to do and
now that I've sent my kind of done it
now that for me things were fun we're
never used to around yourself with
people you love and the people that you
care about and the people that make you
laugh the people that make you just feel
warm and cozy inside and I'm ready to go
home I miss all of you give it the Jazz
version right there
[Music]